we have shared the ordinary and
extraordinary
now we are upon our 20th season and
still have so much more of our journey
to share
after 14 years the sun is setting over
calabasas
it's a beautiful thing to get along in a
new trailer for keeping up with the
kardashians the final season of the tv
phenomenon is starting to feel more real
our family has invited cameras inside
our homes to document our most personal
moments
the sneak peek highlights all the loose
ends i don't know if mom has any more to
give
i want kids badly soon too and teases
some new drama
i feel like a loser while it's not
directly explained
kim's tear-filled moment might indicate
her divorce from kanye west will play
out on the final season
i think she's totally fine otherwise she
won't be hanging out with you 24-7
in a previous sneak peek chloe and
tristan thompson spoke about
expanding their family i don't know
true's getting older
and i just feel like it's now time
to have another kid chloe has opened up
about freezing her eggs
and now we see the couple has taken
additional steps to having another child
via surrogate you're trusting the
surrogate with your unborn child
and it's just scary talking about having
another child together
you don't want to say you're official
i'm not like secret
as for scott and courtney i'm just like
living life and
whatever happens happens at the moment
both exes are in highly publicized
relationships
courtney with travis barker and scott
with amelia hamlin
thinking about proposing and yet this is
just the latest in a series of moments
that speculate if their romance could be
rekindled
can you see yourself getting married to
scott i love you
we also see chris tease an emotional
talk with ex
caitlyn jenner got a call from caitlin
but i just don't know
am i going to want to go down this road
i don't know if mom has any more to give
last year caitlyn gave e.t her reaction
to the series coming to an end
i have to ask how you feel about it
ending they just announced this the show
is ending
i talked to all the kids i talked to kim
yesterday i talked to him and
you know they have done
such a magnificent job and taking that
show
and building their own careers outside
of the show
i mean look i mean kim has done just
such a strong business woman chloe
courtney uh
kendall and kylie you know they have
their own careers right now
um and they use that format so well
that there's a million things to do you
know
um and so i think in some ways they
might be a little bit relieved
that you know it's it's over with but on
the other hand
it was such a great format for the
entire family uh
we'll all we'll always miss that you
know we're talking over
500 episodes 20 seasons
i mean by far they built the most the
best reality series ever in history you
know
i mean it's epic yeah
you